Hello.
My name is Kathy
Pham, and I am here
to tell you about
my story, "Falling
in Love with Computer Science."
It all started in high school.
I didn't know what
programming was.
I had no idea what
computer science was,
but I had a great
geometry teacher
who decided to bring programming
to our school that year.
Thanks, Mrs. Strife.
She came up to me
and basically asked
if I wanted to
take a programming
class my senior year.
And I figured, oh a computer
class-- easy thing to do.
I will just cruise on
by, have one easy class
for my senior year
before graduation.
It wasn't super easy,
but it turned out
I completely loved programming.
I loved building a
program to write up
a receipt where I
entered information
like apples and
oranges and tax rate,
and it printed out a receipt
that is completely customized
to what I want it to be.
And from that
moment, I knew there
was something about
this programming thing
that I really enjoyed.
So when I went to college
next year at Georgia Tech,
I had to pick a major.
I had no idea what I
should do and figured,
you know what, I'll just
pick computer science
and I can always
change it later.
Turns out I really, really
enjoyed my first year.
The class is in Scheme,
similar to Pascal.
No one had heard
of Scheme either,
and it was just this language
with lots of parentheses.
I loved it, nonetheless.
I loved the way it made
me think logically,
and I just loved
writing functions
that can do what I told it to.
So then I continued to really
fall in love with the College
of Computing at Georgia Tech.
I loved staying up
studying late at night.
I became a student
ambassador for Google
and brought pizza to all
of our study sessions.
I loved my professors, advisors,
the classes and really just
had a great time.
But it wasn't always easy.
I had a really hard
time my freshman year.
I put up a PuTTy screen
here because I remember
a moment when during class
the teaching assistant taught
us to go home and log into one
of the College of Computing
servers.
I didn't really know
what a server was, didn't
know what a terminal was.
I just had no idea what
he was talking about
and just remember thinking,
oh, man, this isn't for me.
And I had a great TA
that had me install PuTTy
and showed me how to
SSH into a terminal,
and it was great after that.
But that really drove me to be
a teaching assistant, as well,
so I could help other
freshman students
who came to the College of
Computing a little confused
like I was.
So that was also a lot of fun.
After that during my
time at Georgia Tech,
I explored lots of
different things.
I knew I was interested in
health care to the point
where I actually was taking
pre-med classes-- thought I
might want to go to med school.
And I thought, well, you know
I should explore everything
and had a research assistantship
at a microarray bioinformatics
lab at Georgia Tech.
And I fell in love
with the idea of using
data and bioinformatics to do
something good for the world.
So that led to an
internship at Google.
I interviewed for
a summer internship
as an associate product
manager at Google.
One of my interviewers
had asked,
tell me just something that
isn't really on your resume
that you just really care about.
So I started talking
about my love
for health care, that
I had done some work
in this microarray lab,
really liked bioinformatics.
I didn't think it had
anything to do with Google
because Google did search
and maps and email.
And turns out they were looking
for someone for Google Health
that summer.
So I spent the summer
with some of these interns
here and really absolutely
loved learning more
about computer science
and data and just learning
how it all can tie
together in health care.
So I loved computer
science so much
that I decided to stay
for a master's program.
I flew over to Paris, France.
And I had a great excuse to tell
my mom I was doing something
with my life but really go live
and enjoy my time in France
while getting a
computer science degree.
The university was actually
in this beautiful city
called Metz, a little
outside of Paris.
And I had my computer
science program
jointly with Supelec,
a French university.
I learned conversational
French, learned to absolutely
love and embrace the
French culture and food,
met some wonderful
friends, and also
had an internship at INRIA,
a French research institute.
So I had a wonderful time there.
Near the end of my time
as a graduate student,
I had an opportunity
to participate
in the Microsoft Imagine Cup.
That's basically the World Cup.
But instead of for
soccer, it's for nerds.
And it's held in a
different city every year.
I found a partner to enter
with me into this competition,
and we actually ended
up with the first place
in the Microsoft Imagine Cup and
had a wonderful time building
a tool to address one of the
United Nations Millennium
Development Goals.
So after I graduated, I
had to figure out something
to do with my life
in the real world.
I got a wonderful
opportunity to go live along
the Space Coast of Florida
and work at Harris Healthcare
Solutions, finding
ways to use software
to find solutions for some
of the hospital problems
that we have today.
And what that also meant
was that I saw many rocket
launches, I learned
to surf, and I
got to live along the
Space Coast of Melbourne
and just really enjoy
wonderful, beachy lifestyle.
But I missed the big city.
So I had an opportunity then
to become a business consultant
for IBM, building and
testing data warehouses
for hospital clients around the
country in many cool cities.
One of my fondest
memories while I did this
was when I ran my first
ever half marathon.
I trained for my first
ever half marathon
with my team that was in
Nashville with me at the time
while I was living in Orlando.
So I had a lot of fun times
flying around with IBM.
However, it wasn't
always fun times.
There were times
when I was delayed,
late nights on Thursdays.
This is a photo of when I was
snowed in in Roanoke, Virginia
one time.
And I really just
missed my family
after flying around for so long.
So I found a new role.
At that time, Google was
hiring for a data analyst role.
So I came back to Google.
So I'm currently a data analyst
for our staffing and hiring
and all the people data.
But before I actually
could start at Google,
my mom was diagnosed
with leukemia.
And I never thought
that everything
I had learned with computer
science, with health care,
with program management, with
consulting, with learning
to just fly around on
last minute's notice
would really prepare me for one
the important roles I'd ever
have in my life.
And that was be a patient
advocate for my mom
during her battle with leukemia.
She was diagnosed last
year in August 2013,
and I'm happy to
say that she had
her last round of chemo
on October 6-- one year
and two months after diagnosis.
Hurray!
So that gives me time
to go back to Google
and continue my love affair
with computer science,
focusing on data.
I also do things like Girls Who
Code on the side and support
our K through 12
initiatives, in addition
to working with our business
intelligence community
here at Google.
So what's really
started out as a chance
encounter in high school has
turned into many academic,
personal, and professional
adventures of computer science
I don't know what
the future holds,
but I'm excited to
continue this adventure.
And I hope that your passions
and love for whatever field
you decide to join-- and
maybe it is one related
to science, technology,
engineering, or math--
will take you on many
great adventures as well.
Thank you.